sometimes you just want to relive a
moment of glory from mario kart 8 and
that's exactly what Mario Kart TV is for
it's an online portal where you can
upload your mario kart replays but
unfortunately it will be shutting down
on April fourth Nintendo issued a
statement saying the Mario Kart TV
website which lets you watch highlight
videos posted for Mario Kart 8 will be
closing down as of 11 p.m. pacific time
on Monday April 4 2016 even after the
website shuts down it will still be
possible to watch mariokart TV and
upload highlights from within mario kart
8 itself highlight videos uploaded to
YouTube from the game will not be
deleted after the website shuts down
it's a bummer to see the replay specific
site go away but considering you can
still watch replays in the game itself
and upload them to YouTube I've got a
feeling Mario Kart players will be just
fine to keep up with all the Mario Kart
news take a lap with gamespot we're like
200 cc's of internet fuel
you